at the start of the movie a
father-daughter Duo climb up The Troll
Hills in Western Norway as a hobby after
they reach the top the father Tobias
tells his young daughter Nora about the
folklore of the legendary trolls
apparently these mythical creatures
wandered the Earth several thousand
years ago but one day they were cast
into stone when they came into contact
with sunlight Tobias a renowned
folklorist believes that trolls still
wander around the mountains of Norway
and his daughter is fascinated by it
fast forward 20 years into the future
Nora has outgrown her belief in Magic
and has instead turned to science now
she works as a paleontologist after
working for almost six months at an
archaeological site she finally
discovers a mysterious fossil elated
that her hard work finally paid off Nora
celebrates her recent finding with her
team in the nearby Dover mountains rapid
construction is taking place to build a
metro station the workers are busy
drilling into the mountain and setting
up explosives to create a passageway for
the project meanwhile a crowd of active
is protesting against the construction
shouting that the government should let
the mountain live ignoring their
protests the chief sets off the
explosives blowing the mountain into
Smithereens he makes hard eye contact
with the activists when he hits the
button too Savage he and the workers
then go inside the Dover cave to check
but shockingly they hear a loud roar
moments after they feel the ground shake
and an ancient mythical creature rises
from the rocky depths of the mountain
horrified the workers run for their
lives but the falling mouth and debris
eventually seals their fate shortly
after the news of the incident reaches
the Norwegian Armed Forces headquarters
in Oslo the general decides to send an
aircraft to get clear images of what
really happened at the site he then
gives instructions to alert the Prime
Minister next we see the Norwegian prime
minister and her advisor Andreas heading
to the military base on their way the
Minister of Defense updates them on the
situation and reveals that over 50
people died in the incident he then
displays some pictures of ground zero
and with a closer view we can see
gigantic holes in the ground Andreas
says they look like Footprints but he's
not qualified to have an opinion
meanwhile Nora is still celebrating with
her colleagues on the occasion of her
groundbreaking discovery she begins to
give a speech but suddenly a military
helicopter arrives then a soldier comes
out and tells Nora that she's been
summoned by the prime minister in Oslo
wasting no time she gets on the chopper
and heads towards the military base
after her arrival she is escorted by
Andreas to a room full of government
officials Nora joins them as they
discuss the current situation the
officials presume that the destruction
was caused by some kind of gas but Nora
says otherwise after reviewing the
footprint image closely she suspects it
could be a prehistoric animal that has
risen from the mountains Andreas says it
could be Supernatural but he's not
qualified to have an opinion however the
government officials simply mock Nora
stating that this isn't one of her
fossil research cases they also rule out
the possibility of an animal being
behind all of this just then Sigrid a
computer genius who also works for the
Norwegian Armed Forces barges in and
tells the group that she has managed to
retrieve a video from the incident when
she plays it the officials notice an
approximately 150 foot tall figure
coming out of the Dover cave this
finally convinces them that something
colossal probably a monster has arrived
in Norway elsewhere in a remote area
called Alessia an elderly couple sits
for afternoon tea when they hear a
distant Roar soon after their table
begins shaking causing the nearby
utensils to fall off the couple thinks
it is an earthquake so they quickly hide
under their safety Vault once everything
is settled down they leave the vault
only to find their house shattered and
torn into debris meanwhile Nora tells
the Prime Minister that she is ready to
look into the Dover incident the other
officials agree and she is assigned as a
Scientific Advisor after the meeting the
PM's advisor Andreas informs Nora about
the lessia incident and the two quickly
fly a chopper to the site during their
flight they have a bit of small Andreas
properly introduces himself and then
asks Nora why she became a
paleontologist the latter replies that
she has always loved nature ever since
she was a child she also shares that her
father Tobias was a folklore expert but
he eventually lost touch with reality as
his beliefs went too far at one point
his condition became so bad that he had
to be admitted to a hospital Andreas
then confides in Nora that he always
wanted to be a writer and that he's
working on a story about a monk that
rips his own head off and throws it at
enemies to bite them and I honestly just
found this really funny Once Nora and
Andreas reach the site they are taken
aback by the destruction soon they are
greeted by Captain Chris home Special
Operations Command Chris briefs the two
about the situation explaining that the
creature continued its track two miles
Seth into the mountains but although
they did a sweep of the area they
couldn't find anything it's almost as if
the gigantic creature disappeared Into
Thin Air following this the trio
interviews the elderly couple who are
still shaken up by the incident the wife
reveals that she did not see any thing
however she did hear a strange howling
sound the sound was terrifying much like
that of King Kong it was also mournful
and sad unfortunately the information is
inconclusive Sonora is left to inspect
the surroundings by herself suddenly she
smells a strange odor that leads her
into one of the giant Footprints Nora
then scans the area for any clues but
strangely there are no biological signs
in it it's almost as if the creature is
not a living organism at all now with
all evidence leading to a dead end Nora
decides to seek help from her estranged
father who is living in a remote
Mountain alone Nora Captain Chris and
Andreas fly to his place in a chopper
their first encounter is a bit hostile
but Tobias eventually calms down and
takes them inside his house surprisingly
even after all these years he is still
researching the mythical creatures known
as trolls after a while the group shows
him the video that Sigrid retrieved
earlier Tobias is taken aback by what he
sees and he starts murmuring they are
here confused Nora wants a scientist
explanation not just some folklore to
find a solution to whatever they are
dealing with Daddy stop talking about
trolls and tell me about this troll
however Tobias stands with his theory
and explains that the trolls went
extinct because of the christianization
of Norway he adds that he was about to
reveal the truth until he was belittled
as a maniac he then grabs his bag and
says that they are going on an adventure
next we see Nora her colleagues and
Tobias flying on a chopper to a certain
site after a while they arrive at the
said site and Tobias eagerly begins to
look around the surroundings he notices
that the topography has been completely
changed meanwhile Nora gets a whiff of
the same strange smell which she calls
hypernature I have no idea what she
means by this and it's never explained
so that's that as she scans around the
place suddenly she sees a large figure
waking up behind her it is the mammoth
troll that has camouflaged himself to
blend in with his surroundings Andreas
and the others also noticed this and
quickly start the chopper fortunately
the group Escapes in the neck of time
dude that troll has a tail once they
reach a safe location they go live on
the internet and show the video to the
government officials in Oslo now
everyone is bound to believe that the
trolls are real shortly after the Prime
Minister arranges for a military
operation led by Captain Chris soon
hundreds of soldiers gather around with
the best artillery in the country and
prepare to take down the giant as they
prepare for the duel Tobias Sonora have
a heartwarming father-daughter moment
bonding for the first time in years and
meanwhile Andreas tells Captain Chris
that he knows all about army gear
because he plays Call of Duty then the
troll arrives and the military goes Buck
Wild however despite their best efforts
the troll doesn't seem to be affected at
all he appears to have regeneration
powers and can also smell the blood in
his victims after killing one of the
soldiers Tobias stands up and attempts
to calm the creature down arms
outstretched he seems to be successful
initially at the same time another
vehicle arrives and pummels the troll
with several bullets as it turns and
squashes the people inside Tobias is
inadvertently thwacked with the Troll's
tail sending him flying and crashing to
the ground he tries to say something to
Nora but sadly passes away before he can
elaborate on his words that night a
devastated Nora goes through her
father's Journal trying to figure out
how to stop the troll or at least
understand him better after hours of
reading she learns that the trolls used
to throw Boulders at churches as they
hated the sound of bells later she
shares the information with the
officials claiming that they have to
think out of the box the Minister of
Defense doesn't want to move forward
with such a far-fetched superstitious
plan but since they have no better
option the general and the Prime
Minister give her the green light in the
next scene we see four military
helicopters each attached with a large
church bell moving towards the troll the
plan appears to work at first and the
troll becomes visibly weak but after a
while he gets used to it and destroys
most of the choppers with this Nora's
idea of attacking the monster with
church bells fails spectacular clearly
causing even more Massacre and
destruction however the troll does save
a small child from his imminent demise
showcasing once again that the Beast
appears to feel emotions to make matters
worse at this point news outlets from
around the world have picked up the
story and are broadcasting it in the
aftermath the Prime Minister gives a
speech on TV to try and calm the nation
At first she apologizes for her
cabinet's incompetence and then declares
a state of emergency she also urges the
residents of Oslo and other surrounding
areas to immediately evacuate as for
some reason the troll appears to be
headed straight for the capital
meanwhile due to her failure Nora loses
her seat at the table on the other hand
Andreas learns that the government plans
to bomb Oslo in hopes of destroying the
troll he has some thoughts on this but
he's still not qualified to have an
opinion so he resigns from his position
both Nora and Andreas then leave the
headquarters in no time thousands of
people start queuing up to leave the
city Andreas and Nora are also among
them the latter is still gutted that she
couldn't find a solution to the troll
problem and decides to take one last
look at her father's Journal lo and
behold she finds a clue she notices the
word sending written multiple times in
the journal Andreas tells her that
sending is actually a prince living in
the Royal Palace in Oslo how did Nora
not know about that he apparently is one
of the wealthiest guys in the country
hearing this Nora insists that they turn
the car around and head back believing a
clue lies in the Royal Palace in Oslo
after a while they arrive at the palace
and meet Reichard cinding who also
appears to be waiting for them then he
takes them inside and finally reveals
the truth about the trolls of Norway as
it turns out Tobias was right all along
these mythical creatures actually used
to walk the country's lands at the
palace Nora and Andreas are taken deep
into the underground tunnels where
sinding reveals that he and the other
officials destroyed tobias's life in
order to protect their secrets when
Nora's dad got too close to the truth
sending himself arranged for the old man
to be committed to a mental health
hospital to protect the secret and that
secret happens to be the skeletal
remains of a troll family underground
the Royal Palace was built on top of the
troll King's cave after the Christians
massacred his family and left him for
dead inside the mountain here we get to
know that the troll which is wreaking
havoc around the country is actually the
troll King this explains why the giant
is heading towards Oslo in the first
place he's been trying to return home
sending continues to explain that
nothing is more important to trolls than
family and during the christianization
of Norway the troll King was lured to
the Dover mountain and imprisoned of
course the earlier explosives let him
out and now he's heading back to Oslo to
try and reunite with his children it's
actually quite sad Nora and Andreas are
shocked to learn the truth they are even
more terrified when they see the
skeletal remains of the troll family
when Nora shines her UV light on the
bones she notices that they Sizzle this
is when she realizes that the trolls are
indeed sensitive to light and comes up
with a plan Bilbo Baggins was on to
something after all God damn it next
Nora asks sending to lend her the
biggest vehicle he's got so he provides
her with the Queen's favorite pickup
truck after this she phones Captain
Chris and briefs him about the plan she
wants to surround the troll King with
tanning beds and expose him to UV lights
while Chris calls on some fellow
soldiers to make the troll trap
including the one black character in
this entire movie he was there for no
more than tokenism Andreas asks his
friend Sigrid back at the government
facility to delay the Oslo missile
bombing plan fortunately Sigrid turns
out to be a hacking genius and she
successfully stops the fighter plane
from firing missiles at the creature
with Oslo still intact and the plan very
much alive Andrea Sonora jump into
action at first they remove a large tarp
from the back of the truck and reveal a
troll child's skull they found
underground they then drive away luring
the incoming giant towards the UV light
trap a while later the troll
inadvertently smashes the skull and
realizes that he has no family left
enraged he then turns his attention to
Nora and Andreas determined to make them
pay elsewhere at the military base
Sigrid is eventually caught red-handed
while she's tampering with the missile
system however the general commands her
to abort the missile plan when they
confirmed that there are civilians
nearby meanwhile Nora and Andrea somehow
managed to lure the troll to their
designated spot wasting no time military
vehicles surround him and begin shining
massive UV lights on him the plan works
and the troll slowly Burns to death
however seeing the Giants suffer Nora
has a last minute change of heart she
realizes it's wrong to kill the creature
so she turns off the lights which for
some reason aren't being guarded by the
military guys and tries to save his life
she then urges the troll to go to the
mountains where he can be safe but
unfortunately it's too late there's a
moment of Tranquility until suddenly
Sunrise hits prompting the troll King to
collapse in a heap just before he
completely turns to Stone Nora reaches
out and touches him gently this thing
looks kinda like my dad Nora thinks
while everyone else is rejoicing Andrea
Sonora start wondering whether more
trolls could be hiding deep inside
Norway's mountains Nora then decides
they should call the this area Tobias
Boulder the Prime Minister shows up and
says to Nora that she doesn't know what
to say she then proceeds to to do
exactly that she literally says nothing
to our hero in the final scene the movie
jumps over to Dover Mountain where we
can see a whole bunch of stones move
suddenly another troll rises from the
rubble ready to unleash hell on the
people of Norway Look Out Boys it's
troll time
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching